we've got amazing stunt sequences and
drama sequences it's time to head into
the grishaverse
shadow and bone is arguably one of
netflix's best
with its mystic vibes and magical and
angsty
characters we're not remotely surprised
to make the series even better we got
our hands dirty and dug up some of the
juiciest behind the scenes secrets we
could find
did you know that they had to make up an
entirely new language
if you've read shadow and bone you know
just how huge the grecia verse really
is that meant bringing the series to
life visually took a lot of planning
before any working in the studio started
the animators and filmmakers sat down
and created some epic content sketches
just look at how detailed they are from
mapping out the unruly
shadows and the vulca that wander within
everything was covered
for the actors the experience was a
little nerve-wracking they may have had
the script and acted out their magical
scenes
but they never got to see how the
effects would incorporate them into the
vfx and cgi universe until the final cut
actor archie renault was extremely
nervous about the visual effects not
being up to par
and ultimately making the series a flop
he took a huge sigh of relief when he
realized they had a good show on their
hands
we don't blame them according to archie
all they had to reference during cgi
heavy scenes were sticks with tennis
balls or
wooden models getting into character
required a lot of attention
with a budget nowhere near that of game
of thrones the vfx is comparable and
that's seeing a lot
we can only wonder if maybe the price of
the show's visual effects is the reason
why netflix could only afford a budget
of eight
episodes for shadow and bones season one
i'm
rooting the visual effects might be
iconic but without the amazing cast they
wouldn't have had the footage of the
stunts to add visual effects to sure
the set had stunt doubles on hand but
the shadow and bone cast performed the
majority of their stunts
themselves from rope work to learning
how to ride horses
the cast worked hard and trained for
months to get them right
and they're nothing but proud of their
work just listen to amita suman brag
about having a battle scar from
performing a fight scene
was from about actually don't worry
though they did have professionals
performing the more dangerous stunts
that we see
it's part of my job as much as the cast
loved performing their own stunts they
probably could have done without
performing them in the costumes they had
to wear
we're willing to bet the clothes they
wore while training were a lot more
mobile actress jessica maylie even came
out and spoke about her nightmare
experience with having to go to the
restroom in the costume
how many layers was it again jessica ben
barnes even commented that his entire
costume was held together by a hairpin
without it it would have fallen apart
we're trying to figure out how exactly
he managed to do some of his stunts
without that happening
not to mention his cloak that was so
heavy it required two
other people just to put it on archie
also needed a little extra help with his
costume
his boots were basically impossible to
get off without someone's help
but eventually he learned some tricks
the costume struggles began even before
filming
anita says she had to go through
multiple fitting because energy's knives
just weren't sitting on her body right
it's just as well this outfit is
ridiculous
while we know a lot of effort went into
bringing the magic of shadow and bone to
life using visual effects there is
hardly any green
screen used for their actual locations
and background shots
because they got to film in budapest and
the countryside of hungary
the beautiful architecture and mountain
landscapes you see
are for the majority of the time a
hundred percent real
ben barnes gushed about how cool it was
to film in the castles
brb booking a trip to budapest asap
before any of the above could even be
possible the filmmakers had to get
together and do something called world
building
world building is exactly what it sounds
like they essentially took what was
already known from the books
and crafted an entire physical world
including brand new languages
the languages rav khan and suli were
created by the same person
david j peterson who invented the
dothraki and valerian languages we hear
being spoken in game of thrones
they went in deep even the labels books
and playing card props have the ravkhan
and silly languages
inscribed in them anyone up for learning
another language with us
as for the aesthetics of the series the
sets were created using reference to
countries like russia
amsterdam mongolia and china where are
you from
west bravka it was cool to read on the
set of shadow and bone because if you
didn't
you'd be completely lost the events and
characters in the book were being
constantly referenced by everyone
and helped the cast members understand
everything in more depth
if they weren't sure how a character
would react in a certain moment
they would stick their noses back into
the book and pull out the answer
but kit young admitted it actually
caused some issues at times
it's refreshing to hear how much effort
went into this series from everyone
involved
because we knew everything we had to
kind of go hang on
the audience doesn't know that yet we
uncovered that the actors took their
fair share of props and costume pieces
from the set
and we absolutely don't blame them
frederick carter literally took his cane
and gloves
and isn't the least bit sorry confessing
in an email is clearly the way to go
if only kit had done the same instead he
asked if he could take parts of his
costume but just
didn't have any luck on the bright side
he did manage to keep four of the prop
weapons he used on set
other members didn't quite take big
things like frederick and kit
but managed to swipe some poker chips
and coins as souvenirs
this is all right isn't it but the
damage was done
i've just got all the guns the most
challenging part of creating the entire
series was left up to author
leigh bardugo and co-creator eric
heisserer
we all know the story of elena starkov
on her quest to learn magic and save her
country but lee has another series
called six of crows
that had to be worked into the show as
well lee and eric had to rewrite entire
character prequels just to make it work
and rework the timeline
in a way that made sense so if you had
read the books and were a little
confused as to how the two series were
meshed together
here's your answer look gracious women's
scamming
okay what would an epic series be
without an
even more epic theme song and soundtrack
it was composed by joseph trapenezi
who has already created epic music for
projects like divergent
the greatest showman and tron for the
theme song they stuck with the slavic
theme
in order for it to fit perfectly with
the series russian-inspired roots
author lee even gave it her stamp of
approval the first time she heard it
after spending months in budapest
together it's no surprise that the cast
became the best of friends
just one look at their instagram
accounts and you get a sneak peek
at how much of a family they became both
on and off set
amita said that the connection she had
to everyone is what made the experience
amazing for her she was convinced she
had met kit
before the chemistry read because of
their strong connection
for some reason i was just like mate
have we met before
i said their love for one another
translated into love for their
characters
the series became so important to them
that inej kaz's
and jasper's weapons were all presented
in a ceremony
because of how iconic they were even
shadow and bone author lee became part
of their family
just take a look at how emotional they
were the first time they met one another
one thing is for sure their chemistry
definitely translated on screen
who are you the magic we see our
favorite shadow and bone characters
conjure
may look effortless for them but a lot
of behind the scenes work went into
having this series come to life
it definitely gives their audience a
whole new perspective
on what they see on screen which behind
the scenes secret surprised you most
[Music]